Chistiane tobira de laanon bonjour
bonjour madame camouli alors fallait-il
une loi pour reconnaître l'esclavage
crime contre l'humanité le Code noir qui
déclarait que l'esclave est un bien
meuble qui expliquait que le maître
avait le droit à la première fuite de
lui couper l'oreille et de le marquer à
la fleur de Liss à la deuxème fuite de
lui couper le Jaret et de le marquer à
la fleur de Liss à la troisième fuite de
le mettre à mort ce Code Noir a séjourné
dans le droit français pendant près de 2
siècles seul une loi solennelle disant
la volonté du peuple français pouvait
contrebalancer et dire très clairement
que la France fidèle à ce qu'elle
représente dans l'imaginaire universel
fidèle à sa réputation de patrie des
Droits de l'Homme la France des Lumières
reconnaît aujourd'hui que ce crime qui
était légal qui était officiel qui était
justifié également par des textes
ecclésiastiques ce crime était un crime
contre l'humanité et en fait elle fait
son travail de nation phare dans le
monde en disant la première qu'elle
reconnaît qu'elle se désolidarise de ce
crime et qu'elle reconnaît que c'était
un crime contre l'humanité alors
concrètement qu'est-ce qui va changer
euh l'esclavage crime contre l'humanité
est déjà reconnu dans le code pénal
l'esclavage non daté l'esclavage non
localisé l'esclavage en tant que
générique est effectivement classé parmi
les autres crimes contre l'humanité
cette tragédie qui a duré 4 siècles qui
a saigné l'Afrique qui a mis en contact
dans le commerce triangulaire l'Europe
l'Afrique les Amériques et la Caraïb
ainsi que l'océan Indien cette tragédie
qui a concerné entre 15 et 70 millions
15 millions entre 15 et 30 millions
arrivés aux Amériques mais probablement
70 millions puisque les historiens
disent qu'il faut compter CIN fois plus
puisqu'il y a eu des morts pendant les
rasia et pendant la traversée donc cette
tragédie là très précise qui a concerné
l'ensemble de l'Europe qui a enrichi les
ports atlantiques qui a bâti des
fortunes qui est à l'origine de nos
sociétés de nos sociétés plus culturel
mais de nos sociétés longtemps
traumatisé cette tragédie là en tant que
telle n'était pas encore nommée alors
auriez-vous souhaité que la France fasse
acte de repentance je ne demande pas à
une République laïque de faire un acte
de contrition donc que la repentance
pour moi ne relève absolument pas de
l'acte de légiférer et de la
reconnaissance par un exécutif qui
s'honore en proclamant haut et fort les
valeurs de la République alors vous le
savez cette notion de crime contre
l'humanité a fait l'objet de controverse
l'an passé au moment des émoration
notamment entre les juristes et les
intellectuels explication
su de l'opportunité et de l'intérêt de
reconnaître la traite négrière comme
crime contre l'humanité les avis sont
partagés non pas sur la condamnation
morale mais sur l'utilité d'une telle
proposition de loi d'un côté les
intellectuels emmenés entre autres par
l'écrivain antillet édard glissant ils
estiment qu'une telle reconnaissance
permettrait de conjurer certains nit de
l'histoire
coloniale ensemble encore nommons la
traite et
l'esclavage perpétré dans les Amériques
crime contre
l'humanité regard tourné non pas vers le
passé mais vers l'avenir pour Federico
Maor Directeur général de l'UNESCO
l'intérêt d'un tel texte réside avant
tout dans le message qu'il
véhicule ce qui compte vraiment c'est
dire à tout le monde qu'aujourd'hui nous
devons dans notre tête aussi finir avec
le colonialisme avec l'esclavage avec
l'imposition de les uns sous les autres
du côté des juristes en revanche les
avis convergent pour considérer qu'un
tel texte n'aurait pas de valeur
juridique et donc pas d'effets concrets
l'examen de cette proposition de loi
peut rendre un peu perplexe dans la
mesure où il s'agit euh d'une
condamnation de principe sur lequel bien
entendu je suis en accord total avec ce
texte mais on voit difficilement euh les
effets concrets que le texte peut avoir
au moins pour le passé une position qui
néanmoins n'a pas empêché l'adoption de
ce texte soutenu par la commission des
lois alors Christian tobira deslanon les
juristes on l'a vu en tout cas une
partie d'entre eux étaient sceptique à
l'époque le gouvernement aussi seul
Laurent Fabius sétait déterminé en
faveur de l'esclavage crime contre
l'humanité est-ce que ce n'est pas parce
que cette notion de crime contre
l'humanité impliquait
réparation je n'en suis pas sûr mais je
ne sais pas parce qu' se sont pas
prononcés là-dessus moi je citerai
d'autres juristes pierre trug procureur
général de Paris qui dit très
précisément que c'était un crime contre
l'humanité que cette déportation de
population d'Afrique aux Amériques
réglementé par le Code noir était un
crime contre l'humanité Mireille Delmas
Marti définit le crime contre l'humanité
comme étant l'atteinte à la part la part
d'homme éternel qui se trouve en chacun
d'entre nous il est incontestable que la
situation des esclaves était atteinte
euh dans sa sa part éternelle d'être
humain mais euh ce qui est surtout
important c'est de savoir s'il y a une
contestation manifestement il n'y en a
pas euh c'est l'utilité alors ça peut
être effectivement une démarche de
juriste de s'interroger sur l'utilité
notamment les conséquences pénales euh
mais il y a d'autres intellectuels il y
a des philosophhe politique je pense à
Louis salam Molin qui explique bien
clairement euh donc la question est de
savoir si parce que pendant 150 ans on a
organisé l'oubli et le silence on
continue à l'organiser pendant des
millénaires ou on constate que le non
dit est un traumatisme pour un certain
nombre de sociétés pour des peuples
entiers et qu'on y mette un terme alors
on a bien vu que c'était effectivement
l'objectif de cet article de loi tout de
même le mot réparation qui était dans
votre texte initial a disparu est-ce que
vous le regrettez
aujourd'hui je le regrette dans un sens
où je pense que c'est un concept en
construction qui que sa construction
aurait commencé et aurait été
substantiel durant nos débats à
l'Assemblée nationale ça a été le cas
d'ailleurs pour une part et que sa
construction va se poursuivre puisque
l'ONU doit examiner une résolution
signée par Israël le Cuba et le Sénégal
visant à reconnaître la traite et
l'esclavage comme crime contre
l'humanité donc la traite négrière Chang
qu'est-ce que ça peut changer ce mot de
réparation ben le problème c'est la
perception qu'il y a sur le terme le
concept pour moi n'a pas d'ambiguïé il
s'agit d'une réparation symbolique la
reconnaissance du crime le fait de lui
donner non et statut il s'agit également
d'une reconnaissance d'une réparation
politique dans le fait de dire qu'il y a
des sociétés qui sont aujourd'hui sur
des fondements inégalit qui sont
déstabilisés essentiellement du fait du
système esclavagiste qui a perduré après
l'abolition en tout cas dans son
organisation sociale ensuite il y a une
réparation morale essentielle le fait de
dire qu'il y a toujours eu des
résistances en Afrique aux Amériques en
Europe et que ces résistances ont été
extrêmement solidaires et ont abouti à
l'abolition mettre tout ça dans les
livres scolaires inciter à la recherche
aux tes universitaire il y a aussi une
réparation culturelle par la
réhabilitation des lieux de mémoire donc
tout ça ce sont des réparation
extrêmement importantes qui n'ont rien à
voir avec des réparations financières et
qui ne sont pas lié non plus à des
jugements dans la mesure où il n'y a pas
de culpabilité héréditaire et qu'il n'y
a plus de survivants parmi les coupables
je remercie beaucoup
Christian